servat lui et j'ai modestement fait mes
débuts sur scène
ah oui selena spectacle de julien non
vous les fait monter sur qui il a fait
un petit sketch sur scène
non mais attends t'es quoi le skate
c'était un petit sketch quoi qu'est ce
qui t'arrive la voiture là tu penses qu
est là et alors c'était quoi et surtout
chp à mon poste un nom i
ccc à rester coi avec un jeu de lumières
j'entre et puis tout d'un coup de gueule
est en fait il était derrière le rideau
intelligente pour ça que c'est
enregistré et l'âge apparaît sur sa
lumière
vous étiez là oui et hurle sur
l'émission après ce retour n'est fait
c'est quelle émission fait
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je dois reconnaître modestement qu'on a
pris le même vent samedi soir